hi everyone
this is professor m science and today i
want to talk about operators
in another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics
what is an operator an operator is the
mathematical object that allows us to
describe physical properties in quantum
mechanics
for example we have the position
operator that tells us about where a
particle
is we have the momentum operator which
tells us what the momentum of a particle
is
or we have the energy operator which
tells us what the energy of a particle
is
in this video i will first of all
introduce operators
and second i will describe some of their
mathematical properties that will be
useful in doing quantum mechanics
so let's get going operators are
fundamental in quantum
mechanics because they describe physical
properties this is reflected by the fact
they feature
in the second postulate of quantum
mechanics which says that a physical
quantity a
is described by an operator which we
write a hat
acting on the state space v and that
this operator is called an observable
posture 2 tells us that operators act on
state space what that means is that they
act on kets which are the vectors of
state space
and therefore they modify these kets in
some manner
we're going to represent the action of
operators on a state space as follows
we're going to write
the operator a hat acting on a ket psi
delivering another ket psi prime and to
be clear
both psi and psi prime are kets that
belong to the state space
the aim of this video is to give you the
tools to understand the mathematics of
operators
for that reason i will keep the
discussion abstract without specifying
what the operator a represents
but when we use operators in actual
quantum mechanical calculations they
will represent quantities such as energy
position and momentum
and you can find many videos in the
description where i do that
one important property of the operators
that we use in quantum mechanics
is that they act on linear superposition
of cats as follows
a acting on a1 psi 1 plus a2 psi2
where psi1 and psi2 are cats and a1a2
are scalars
is such that we obtain a1 a psi1
plus a2 a psi2 operators that act in
this fashion are called linear operators
and we're always going to use linear
operators in quantum mechanics
as i said earlier what i want to do in
this video is to introduce the
mathematical properties of operators
that will be useful when solving quantum
mechanical problems
the two most important properties are
addition and multiplication of operators
so let's start with addition addition is
associative
that means that a plus b plus c is equal
to
a plus b plus c and addition is also
commutative
that means that a plus b is equal to b
plus a
when we look at multiplication the first
thing we have to do is we have to define
what we actually mean by multiplying two
operators together
and in this context multiplication of
operators is defined by its action
on a ket so the product of a and b
acting on a ket psi is defined by first
acting on psi
with b and then acting on the result of
that with a
another way of looking at that is that
the action of b on psi
first gives you another k psi prime and
then you act with
a on that ket psi prime now that we know
how to interpret the product of two
operators we can look at its properties
the first property is the fact that the
product is associative that means that a
times b times c is equal to a times b
times c we next move to one of the most
important properties of operators
which is the fact that under
multiplication they are not
commutative what that means is that in
general
a b is not equal to ba
because operators do not commute under
multiplication
it becomes useful to define a new
quantity which we call
the commutator and we write down the
commutator of two operators
as square bracket a comma b square
bracket
and that commutator is defined as a b
minus
ba commutators and operators that don't
commute play a fundamental role in
quantum mechanics and lead to some of
the most striking features of this
theory
for example two operators that don't
commute are associated with properties
that cannot be measured simultaneously
in a quantum system a very well-known
example of this is the position of
momentum operators which don't commute
which implies that you can never measure
simultaneously the position and momentum
of a quantum particle
the next thing i want to do is to look
at the scalar product or bracket
between a bra psi and the ket a phi
which is obtained by acting with an
operator on another ket
phi the way to interpret this bracket is
that a
phi gives us a ket phi prime
and then we have the bracket between psi
and phi prime
which as we know is a scalar c that in
general is a complex number
the bracket between a bra and the ket
one of which is obtained by the action
of an operator allows us to define
the action of operators on brass so we
can consider this bracket
in the two following ways the first one
is that we have a bra
psi and the ket a5 and then the bracket
is
psi a phi or we can consider this
as a bra psi a and then a ket phi
and the corresponding bracket is psi a
phi
these two expressions are equivalent by
definition and we write them down
as psi a phi when we have a bracket
between a bra and the ket
one of which is obtained by the action
of an operator on another brow or
another ket
we call this object a matrix element in
particular we would call psi
a phi the matrix element of the operator
a
with respect to psi and phi with this
definition of a matrix element
we can think of the operator a as either
acting on the ket
or acting on the bra however if we know
how an operator
acts on a ket to obtain another kit that
still doesn't tell us how it would act
then on a bra
to obtain another bra to do that we need
to introduce the adjoint operator
to introduce the adjoint operator we
need to remember that to every cat in
state space that corresponds a bra in
the jewel space
and if this idea is new to you check the
video in the description where i talk
about dirac notation in state space
where i introduce the ideas of keds and
bras and state space and rule space
what we know so far is after a cat psi
there is a corresponding bra
psi what we want to know is what is the
bra corresponding to the ket psi prime
that is obtained by the action of an
operator a on the ket
psi as always we write the bra
corresponding to the ket
psi prime as the broad psi prime and
then we want to know
how is that psi prime related to the
graph psi
this is where we define the adjoint
operator and we say that the graph psi
prime is equal
to the graph psi and the operator a
dagger where a dagger is the adjoint
operator
at this point a dagger is only
definition if we have an operator a that
acts on a ket
psi and we get another ket psi prime
then a dagger
is the operator that acts on the
corresponding graph psi to get the
corresponding bra
psi prime we happen to call this the
adjoint operator and we happen to
represent it
with this dagger symbol but so far we
don't know anything else about this
operator
so what we have to do next is to try to
understand what are the properties of
this operator given this definition
the very first property is that the
adjoint operator is also a linear
operator
to prove that let's start with the graph
psi that we write as
a1 psi 1 plus a2 psi 2 and then we build
the corresponding ket
psi which is equal to a1 star psi 1 plus
a2 star
psi 2. where you need to remember that
the relation between cats and brass is
anti-linear so we need to take the
complex conjugate of any scalar
we know how an operator acts on a kept
psi so we can write a psi and then
substitute the value of
psi and then use linearity of the
operator to obtain the final expression
at this point we're going to define a
psi as psi prime and similarly a psi 1
and a psi 2
as psi 1 prime and psi 2 prime
this means that we can write the last
expression in terms of the primed kets
and then we can calculate the
corresponding bra as a1 psi 1 prime plus
a2
psi 2 prime now at this point we note
that the primed cats are defined
through the action of the a operator on
the original cats
what that means is that the primed bras
are related to the unprimed brass
through the adjoint operator by the
definition of the adjoint operator
we can therefore rewrite the expression
we have here as a1
psi 1 a dagger plus a2 psi 2
a dagger if instead of working with the
components 1 and 2 we work with the full
ket
phi prime then the corresponding bar is
psi prime which is equal
to the brush psi times a dagger
if we now take this last term and
substitute for the brush psi the
expression above in terms of the
psi 1 and psi 2 brass we can write that
psi a dagger
is equal to a1 psi 1 plus a2 psi 2 a
dagger
and then by comparing it to the
expression here we obtain a1
psi 1a dagger plus a2 psi 2a dagger
putting this together we see that the
action of a dagger on a linear
combination of two brass is equal to the
individual
action of a dagger on each of these bras
and therefore
a dagger is indeed a linear operator
the next thing i want to do is to
revisit the second posture of quantum
mechanics i introduced at the beginning
of the video
that postulate tells us that the
operator associated with the physical
quantity
is called an observable what that means
is that we're only interested in the
subset of operators
that we call observables and these in
fact are defined as operators
which are equal to their adjoint we call
these operators hermitian operators
and they are essential in the theory of
quantum mechanics so you can find the
link in the description where i talk
about the properties
of hermitian operators another very
important subset of operators in quantum
mechanics are operators whose inverse
is equal to their adjoint and we call
such operators
unitary operators again you can find the
video in the description where i talk in
some detail about unitary operators
when you encounter operators in your
study of quantum mechanics for the first
time
it can be quite daunting because they
are rather abstract objects
so it is always a good idea to get some
practice what i have here is a list of
properties of operators and their
adjoints and in the video link in the
description i go one by one
proving each of these properties and i
think that would be good practice for
you to become familiar
with manipulating operators
before i conclude i want to introduce a
final idea that is the fact that we can
represent an operator
as something called an outer product
let's start by considering a bra psi and
the ket
phi and we define the inner or scalar
product
as the bracket between psi and phi which
gives us a scalar which in general is a
complex number
the order of the terms in dirac notation
is very important so if we consider
first the cat phi and then the perhaps i
does this construct have any meaning the
answer to this is yes
this is what we call an outer product
what i want to do now is to show that
the outer product is just another way of
representing an operator
and to do that we consider the outer
product of phi and psi
acting on a ket chi and then we
rearrange the expression to write phi
and then we see that we have the bracket
between psi and chi
this bracket of course is just a scalar
which we call a and therefore we can
write the whole thing as
a phi so what is this outer product
doing
we have the outer product acting on a
cat chi
and the result is another ket a phi this
is precisely the definition of an
operator
an operator is an object that acts on a
ket and gives you another cat
writing operators out of products is
something that happens very often in
quantum mechanics
so it is worth becoming familiar with
this form before i conclude i just want
to say that i usually write 5
psi as shown here and i leave it as an
exercise for you to show that the
adjoint of an outer product
simply reverses the order of the terms
to summarize i have introduced the idea
of an operator a that is an object that
acts on a ket
psi and gives us another ket psi prime
one fundamental property of an operator
a is that it is linear
that means that when it acts on a linear
superposition of two cats
it first acts on the first cat and then
on the second one
if we now want to relate state space to
joule space then the action of an
operator a
on a ket psi is equivalent to the action
of the adjoint operator a dagger
on a bra psi the action of the adjoint
operator on a lean superposition of
brass
is also linear and the final important
property of operators is that the
multiplication of operators
doesn't necessarily commute so this
leaves the definition of the commutator
of two operators
a b minus ba so what have we learned
today
we have introduced operators which are
the mathematical objects that allow us
to describe physical quantities in
quantum mechanics
check out the video i have in the
description where i do some exercises
with operators which is a great way to
become familiar with them
if you like the video or if you like
some suggestions for future videos
please subscribe